[Aplausos]
vamos a hablar dos cosas cuál es el
arquetipo de un puente y cuál es el
arquetipo del papel bueno vamos a
trabajar con eso mientras voy a hablar
les voy a pedir que hagan algo van a
tener el reto de ustedes
de su imaginación inventar un puente que
tenga la capacidad de hacer esto si su
compañero pone sus manos así separadas y
ustedes ponen su celular el puente se va
a sostener ok y me encantaría ver quién
de ustedes logra sostener su celular con
un puente que haga con una hoja de papel
sí y mientras no crean que no me van a
seguir escuchando me van a seguir
escuchando y los voy a retar a que de
repente pongan su imagen en la pantalla
mientras mezclan entre ver la pantalla y
ver lo que están haciendo sí porque
tenemos mucho más capacidad de la que
creemos
entonces por un momento te pido antes
que empieces cierra los ojos
cierra los ojos
imagínate que estás en un lugar
donde hay un puente
y quiero que te hagas la pregunta cierra
tus ojos por favor hasta en la pregunta
como es ese puente es sólido pues de
madera
y pregúntate si ya lo cruzaste o estás
por cruzarlo
y quiero que le mientas toda esa energía
a esto que vamos a hacer
gracias abre los ojos
y empiecen a intentar doblar el papel
mientras yo voy a hacer lo mismo también
voy a ir doblando mi papel mientras les
voy hablando ok
entonces
una de las cosas
que quiero que veas es que es lo que
pasa
con tu mente tu mente tiene dos partes
te fuiste a un lugar racional a un lugar
emocional sentiste algo con eso o no
y hablando de interpretaciones de
puentes
yo no sé chiste te acuerdas de cuando
nos alegrábamos de los puentes se
refiere a otro tipo de puentes cuántas
clases de puentes hay qué es un puente
para ti
qué es un puente para ti ese es uno de
los jeroglíficos de los códices creo que
aztecas
te pido que
te conectes con tu parte emocional cuál
es el sentimiento
que se presenta cuando ves esta imagen
y continuas haciendo tu puente
esto es un puente oral y mira que el
tipo de letra
allí no había puente había una carretera
pero obviamente alguien
deja de poder pasar por qué pasó un
sismo pasó algo como lo que
vivimos hace poco hubo una inundación de
un huracán y se crea un puente aéreo
qué es lo que hace que un puente nos
sostenga
vivimos unos días muy difíciles no
vivimos caerse puentes edificios
completos
y quiero que te preguntes que le faltó a
estos edificios
y también
que mientras estás haciendo tu figura
te pongas a pensar qué es lo que le
puede dar a tu figura la solidez para
sostenerse
y cuando hablo de tu figura no hablo de
tu figura simplemente la que estás
trabajando las manos sino en ti
o sea quién eres tú
ok tienes que ser tú
para
que los puentes que construyas en tu
vida sean sólidos
y al final voy a que voy a pedirles que
escriban algo en una de las hojas de
papel que tienen y lo van a compartir
allá afuera si es que quieren
pero no
qué sientes cuando desde ese puente
te atreverías a cruzarlo
se ve riesgos o no
o s
este tipo de puentes se están haciendo
en canadá y en otros lugares para que
los animales salvajes puedan
cruzar o esto
todo esto es un puente y todo eso ha
sido creado como la anterior o como este
por qué
qué es lo que hace que un puente se cree
vende
unir si la una que la necesidad exacto
una necesidad entonces cuáles son los
puentes que tú necesitas crear y no me
refiero sólo a los físicos miranda más
ese puente el ser humano ha logrado
hacer ese tipo de puentes es impactante
no
bueno no importa que no terminemos
ahorita quiero al final o ya en el break
que entre ustedes se demuestren quién es
cuál de sus puentes si funcionó porque
los voy a poner y los va a arrestar a
hacer otra cosa y es una de estas
columnas entre todos ok
tal vez es mucho pedir no es mucho pedir
bueno entonces esto está formado esto es
una estructura con la cual se pueden
hacer puentes esculturas está hecha
totalmente de papel tiene tres piezas
distintas está cuadriculada
esta que es como una estrellita y este
es como un castillo
entonces cuál es el factor por lo que
los puentes existen porque existe un
puente
se imaginan bandas para cruzar jajaja
la primera vez se acuerdan cómo pasó
alguien antes de que existiera un puente
y ya se ve muy moderno no pero miren s
s ahí como qué
pues apenas estaba
creando una civilización tal vez no
bueno no porque tenemos una vaca para
curar
cuando no hay comunicación qué pasa con
los puentes
no funciona en verdad
que tanto arrojo se requiere para cruzar
un puente
depende del puente ahora mira este no se
necesita nada de rojo verdad
pero mira este otro
perdón por la imagen que estaba pixelada
y no me di cuenta bueno es que la amplió
mucho
pero eso es un caso de la vida real
están cruzando con el puente medio roto
entonces qué significa para ti un puente
alguien sabe quién es qué puente sc
bueno les voy a pedir a todos estos los
de este lado las ocho filas quiero que
me hagan al menos una pieza como está la
doblas a la mitad y luego a la mitad de
la mitad y luego a la mitad de la mitad
y te va a quedar una costilla así
a la mitad las primeras cuatro filas
me van a hacer
como un avioncito sí
o sea doblas a la mitad la figura y le
doblas a 45 grados un lado y a 45 grados
del otro
y cuando lo abres te queda el avioncito
sí y nada más doblas aquí y doblas aquí
te queda esta cuadrícula ok hasta ahí
vamos bien bueno entonces ustedes las
costillitas ustedes primero primeras
filas algunos de ustedes ya estaban
haciendo algo parecido es parecida a la
que el piojito sí
si se acuerdan lo van a poder hacer no
se preocupen si no les sale porque
algunos allá afuera vamos a poder
apoyarlos y los de los de las filas de
atrás lo que van a hacer es lo mismo
tienes una cuadrícula ok la doblas a la
mitad primero
y luego
vas a doblar a la mitad de la mitad de
un lado
y a la mitad de la mitad del otro lado
para que te quede un acordeón una mwv
luego lo abres y lo doblas
transversalmente ellas es lo mismo otra
m otra wv el chiste es que te quede una
cuadrícula de 4 x 4
ustedes piensan que les estoy dando muy
poquito información y muy muy poco
tiempo verdad imagínate que eres un
ciego
imagina que eres un ciego un ciego
dependía del 100% de su escucha yo he
dado a este tipo de cosas con gente
invidente y no tienes idea lo
precisó que es su trabajo porque como no
pueden ver tienen que estar escuchando
los seres humanos no escuchamos eso es
barack obama recordando una una lucha
que hubo por en ese puente precisamente
por derechos humanos de la comunidad
afroamericana y hubo incluso muertos y
desde entonces se conmemora el puente
del amor 5 no se encuentra el amor
cuando ya hay más de uno
el de arriba es león guanajuato el de
abajo es parís donde la gente pone sus
candados los parejas y tiran la llave
para decir esto es eterno
es otro tipo de puente no
y guadalupe reyes
que por cierto ya viene pronto
este
qué tal de las conexiones sinápticas lo
que estoy haciendo al menos intentar
hacer con ustedes ahorita
hacernos las condiciones sin nada
sinápticas retando los a hacer algo que
tal vez no normalmente no hacen hay
algunos de ustedes que probablemente
cuando están escuchando solo están
escuchando y no pueden hacer otra cosa y
si puedes hacer muchas más cosas
yo hago origami mientras estoy en el
cine
es como las viejitas las abuelitas
tejiendo sí
ustedes lo pueden hacer y esto puede ser
desarrollar y puentes entre lo femenino
y lo masculino todos tenemos tuvimos una
performance aquí de gente que vibra
mucho en el medio no entonces el punto
es ese hay puentes en todos lados
cómo se relación de un puente con el
tiempo saben
o sea para que hubiera un puente antes
de que hubiera el puente alguien vivía
de este lado sí
entonces un lado del puente te lleva al
otro
y eso es tiempo de acuerdo
pasado y presente este lugar existe se
llama puente de dios en la huasteca
potosina
cuál es el puente que requieres
construir y cruzar con tan poquita
información ustedes creen que podamos
utilizar lo que ustedes están haciendo
para pararlos en papel
bueno voy a repetir la instrucción
rápidamente ok de este lado a ver
enséñenme
mira esto está perfectísimo buenísimo de
este lado
no necesita más instrucción de ustedes a
ver
muy bien perfecto que se doble así
horizontalmente
y verticalmente sí y para que te quede
eso perfecto muy bien a ver los de atrás
las de atrás les puse el reto más grande
porque no les he dado la última
instrucción
esa última instrucción es esta
han doblado una caja de cartón 4p a dos
una de esas de telas
no me digas que no has tomado una caja
de cervezas en una fiesta bueno lo que
vas a hacer para atrapar la caja es
doblar un lado el de la derecha doblas
el de arriba doblas el de la izquierda
volteas aquí doblas y marcas tu papel
regresas y abres para 4 apear la caja y
meterlo y te va a quedar un reguilete
los de atrás el rey y lete
esta complejo ahora
no pero no es tanto la verdad no es tan
complejo van a ver al final lo que vamos
a poder hacer allá afuera
bueno
ahora te pido si quieres suspende
tantito esto que estás haciendo de las
de las columnas y agarra una hoja de
esas mismas el limpio
te voy a pedir que escribas ok esto para
mí es bien bien importante y creo que
para ustedes también
una de las cosas soy soy con coach
ontológico en el coaching ontológico
habla de el pensamiento se genera cómo
se siente ese pensamiento a veces son
positivos a veces negativos de ahí a qué
es lo que digo acerca de ese pensamiento
y luego lo que hago entonces lo que
quiero que hagan es plasmar empezar a
plasmar algo en términos de cuáles sólo
cuáles son los puentes que requieren
ustedes cruzar
o construir de aquí en adelante
obviamente puentes simbólicos pueden ser
de comunicación o de otro tipo sí pero
el chiste es que lo hagas desde un lugar
con el lenguaje más poderoso posible si
puedes eliminar la palabra tratar
elimina tratar no lleva a ningún lugar
quiero tampoco quiero no se mueve
entonces voy a algunas palabras que te
permitan decirme algo de lo que vas a
hacer para construir esos puentes que
requieres construir ok y lo vas a
escribir en este recuadro y si quieres
lo vamos a poner allá en la escultura
que está allá afuera y también nos va a
servir para al final del día hacer algo
interesante
este es un puente que inventó da vinci
no necesita ni pegamento ni clavos es
creatividad pura incluso para la alguien
de ustedes ya tiene una un diseño para
su
puente y que soporte el peso de él
puede ser hay que probarlo hay que
probarlo ok al rato al rato en el en el
break si quieres lo intentamos cada
quien y ccoo entre ustedes lo puede
hacer a ver que tanto le piden a alguien
que se los
que los apoye
ya ves que si se requieren puentes no
como ven esa imagen
será photoshop no verdad se ve muy
antigua como pasa el photoshop
ayer los diputados salieron del congreso
bueno para contar chistes por eso los
pongo ahí
salieron salieron del congreso a la
carrera para el puente y a los de
abajo les dio miedo porque piensan que
se los van a quitar
este
ven eso
yo evidentemente ahorita no les da
tiempo de hacer eso de qué de qué
material quieren que está hecho ese
puente papel
incluso con el papel que tienes lo
puedes hacer cuando evidentemente en
este caso si requirió de pegamento pero
no necesitas pegamento para hacer un
puente
entonces
hasta aquí hasta aquí terminó eso tengo
tiempo tanto para para darles la última
instrucción verdad bueno cuando tengan
cuatro pesada la pieza está lo tiene lo
que tienes que hacer es nada más doblar
la esquinita ok doblando las esquinas ya
te queda un reguilete en el cual le
puedes meter justamente esta pieza ok
y eso ya tiene que ser en la interacción
entre ustedes
y si quieren allá afuera yo les puedo
apoyar a ustedes entre ustedes se pueden
apoyar y al final
esta pieza entra acá con el trabajo de
todos se puede construir algo como lo de
afuera en este caso son figuras de acero
pero inicialmente las hice de papel y
les quiero compartir qué
esas figuras de acero existen gracias a
mi hija porque está estudiando diseño
industrial ella se le ocurrió hacer esto
mismo que yo hice ya dobló el papel
digo doblo el acero hizo la columna con
el papel o con él con todo el proceso
que yo hago le costó muchísimo pero le
dio un 10 en su escuela
lo más importante
es que me dio a mí la posibilidad de
encontrar un mundo nuevo ya no sólo en
papel sino en acero ósea y es
interesantísimo como las generaciones no
están peleadas las generaciones somos
lo que va construyendo los puentes de
generación en generación y les digo
trabajen nuestro de los mundos de los
jóvenes es de todos los adultos los de
tercera edad
pueden aportar mucha experiencia y los
jóvenes toda esta innovación renovación
etcétera sí
bueno aquí estoy terminando mi puente y
con este puente
no me queda más que darles las gracias y
poner mi celular ahí adentro
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]